N
G
LAW ENACTED IN MARCH GIVES
UNCHECKED POWER TO THE STATE
ELECTION BOARD TO REMOVE LOCAL
ELECTION OFFIALS.
WE HEARD ABOUT THE PARTISAN
TAKEOVERF ECTION AT OUR
FIELD HEARING IN ATLANTA FROM
ONE ELECTION OFFICIAL WHO HAD
BEEN OUSTED BY THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AFTER OVER A DECADE
OF SERVICE.
STEVE: ACCORDING TO BIDEN'S
RANCH IN ATLANTA THIS IS
ELECTIONS AVERSION BUT THERE IS
ALMOST AN IDENTICAL PROVISION IN
THE DEMOCRAT BILL BIDEN WANTS TO
PUSH THROUGH CONGRESS, THE
GEORGIA LAW SAYS STATES CAN
SUSPEND LOC ELECTION OFFICIALS
FOR NONFEASANCE, MALFEASANCE OR
GROSS NEGLIGENCE, BIDEN'S OWN
BILL SAYS STATES CAN SUSPEND
LOCAL ELECTION OFFICIALS FOR
GROSS NEGLIGENCE, NEGLECT OF
DUTY OR MALFEASANCE IN OFFICE,
VOTER ID IS RACIST, VOTER
SUPPRESSION BUT THE MAYOR IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. PAINTED BLACK
LIVES MATTER ON THE STREET
OUTSIDE OF THE WHITE HOUSE AND
INTRODUCED VOTER ID FOR LEAVING
YOUR HOUSE.
>> WHY WAS THE DECISION MADE NOT
TO REQUIRE A BALLOT VOTER ID
WHEN SOMEONE PRESENTS THEIR
COVID VACCINE CARD.
>> WE EXPECT TO RUIRE THAT.
>> SURE ENOUGH, SHE DID A LITTLE
TREAT STARTING SATURDAY YOU'LL
NEED PHOTO ID BEFORE HEADING OUT
IF WE APPLY THE DEMOCRAT VOTING
RIGHT ARGUMENT THAT IS WORSE
THAN VOTER SUPPRESSION THAT IS
EXTRAJUDICIAL HOUSE ARREST FOR
BLACK PEOPLE, TIME TO DEFEND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE CIVIL
RIGHTS TO ARREST BOWSER.
THERE IS A LIE ABOUT DROP BOXES
LAWMAKERS TAKING THEM OFF THE
STREET WHEN THEY WERE PUTTING
THEM ON THE STREETS.
IN 2019 DROP BOXES WERE
COMPLETELY ILLEGAL IN GEORGIA
NOW THERE ENSHRINED IN LAW,
THERE IS A LIE ABOUT MAILING
VOTING THANKS TO THE NEW
REPUBLICAN OR ANYONE IN GEORGIA
CAN REQUEST THE MAIL-IN BALLOT
WHEREAS BIDEN YOU NEED TO GIVE A
REASON.
CHUCK SCHUMER NEW YORK YOU NEED
TO SIGN AN ATTESTATION THAT
YOU'RE OUT OF TOWN, ILL, CARING
FOR SOMEONE THAT IS I IN A
VETERANS FACILITY ORAIL, IT'S
A FELONY TO MAKE US FALSE
STATEMENT FOR AN ABSENTEE BALLOT
THE INSTRUCTION WORN YET SCHUMER
CAUSED THE GEORGIA LAW, HE
POINTED TO THE CONSOLIDATION OF
EARLY VOTING PLACESN ONE RURAL
COUNTY AS BEING PART OF A
JANUARY THE SIXTH TO STOP BLACK
PEOPLE VOTING BUT THE BLACKWOMAN
COUNTY SAYS THEY HAVE BEEN
PLANNING TO CHANGE FOR YEARS IN
ANY CASE WE HAVE ADVANCED VOTING
AND ABSENTEE BALLOTS A WE ALSO
HAVE TRANSPORTATION AND BY THE
WAY A 68% REPUBLICAN COUNTY ON
AND ON IT GOES LIE AFTER LIE
AFTER LIE WHETHER DROP BOXES ARE
MAILING VOTING EARLY VOTING OR
VOTER ID ELECTION RULES WHICH
ARE LESS RESTRICTIVE THAN IN
MANY DEMOCRAT RUN STATES
DESCRIBED BY DEMOCRATS AS THE
NEW JIM CROW.
DID THEY EVER STOP TO THINK
ABOUT AT THEY'RE SAYING AND
WHAT THEIR WORDS MEAN UER JIM
CROW SCHOOLS, RESTAURANTS, BUSES
WERE SEGREGATED IT WAS EVIL,
SHAMEFUL, DISGUSTING AND NOT
PROVIDED IN THE DEMOCRATS HE THE
SPECTER OF JIM CROW TO ADVANCE
THE PARTISAN POWER GRAB, THAT IS
EVIL AND SHAMEL AND THAT IS
DISGUSTING.
BIN, PELOSI KAMALA HARRIS,
THEIR RECKLESS, RACIAL ARSONIST
AND GUILTY OF THE EXACT SAMETHI.
>> IF YOU ASK YOURSELF WHY IT
GETS EVEN WORSE, WHAT IS THE
REASON BIDEN WENT TO ATLANTA TO
DELIVER THE ILL JUDGED APPALLING
RENT, WOULD YOU BELIEVE THAT
CHUCK TODD GAVE US THE ANSWER
THIS MORNING.
>> I WAS TOLD BY SOMEBODY IN
ATLANTA, THE ACTIVISTS ARE
IGNORANT, HE HAD TO DO THIS THAT
WAS ARGUMENT IF HE DID NOT DO
THIS THEY WERE NOT GOING TO HAVE
PEOPLE TO LICK ENVELOPES IN
SENATE RACES AND HOUSE RACES.
STEVE: LICKING EELOPES.
BECAUSE THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT
NOT HAVING ENOUGH PEOPLE TO LICK
ENVELOPES AT THEIR ELECTION
CAMPAIGN THEY RUB SALT IN
ERICA IS PAINFUL WOUNDS THAT'S
WHAT THIS WHOLE THING IS ABOUT
AND IT SHOWS WHAT DEMOCRATS ARE
ALL ABOUT.
FOR THEM IT IS ALWAYS ABOUT
POLICS NOT POLICY, POINT
SCORING NOT PNCIPAL, PANDERING
TO THEIR BASE INSTEAD OF LEAVING
THE COUNTRY.
THE LIES ARE NOT JUST ABOUT
VOTING SPECIFICS, THE WHOLE
STORY IS A LIE THEY SAY
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO
SUPPRESS THE VOTE BECAUSE THEY
FEAR DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE, AND THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION THE
BLACK REPUBLICAN VOTE WITHOUT
THE LATINO REPUBLICAN VOTE WENT
UP A LOT THE LATINO VOTE FOR
DEMOCRATS WENT DOWN A L.
>> THANKS TO TRAPS CONSERVATIVE
POPULISM THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS
BECOMING A MULTIRACIAL
WORKING-CLASS COALITION WHILE
THE DEMOCRATS BECOME THE PARTY
OF THE RICH, WHITE AND WOKE THIS
IS THE FACTUAL DEMOGRAPHIC
REALITY THE MORE THAT NONWHITE
CITIZENS VOTE THE BETTER IT IS
FOR REPUBLICANS IN THE WORSE FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THE DEMOCRATS SAY THE TRYING TO
SAVE DEMOCRACY.
THEY'RE THE ONES UNDERMINING IT.
LOOK WITHIN THEIR VOTING
LEGISLATION NATIONALIZING
ELECTIONS, UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
UNDERMINING VOTER ROLE
ABOLISHING VOTER ID LAWS,
UNCONSCIONABLE IN THE WHOLE
STICKING PILE OF ANTIDEMOCRATIC
CORRUPT GARBAGE CROWNED BY THEIR
ATTEMPT TO EXPAND THE BANANA
REPUBLICTROCITY ABOUT
HARVESTING.
>> AND THEN.
>> THE FORMER PRESIDENTS ALLIES
AND DISENFRANCHISE ANYONE WHO
VOTES AGAINST THEM.
JUST DECIDE WHAT THEY WANT AND
THEN DO IT.
THAT IS WHAT YOU SEE INTO
SOLITARY AND STATES, NOT
DEMOCRACIES.
STEVE: BIDEN RANTS ABOUT
AUTHORITARIANISM, EXCUSE ME WHO
IS SENDING IN THE FBI TO
INTIMIDATE PARENTS WHO DISAGREE
WITH DEMOCRATS WIL POLICY,
WHOSE REGIME IS IT AN ABSOLUTELY
CHILLING NEW DEVELOPMENT THAT
JUST ANNOUNCED THIS.
>> THE VIOLENTXTREMISTS ARE
MOTIVATED BY A MIX OF IDEOLOGY
AND PERSONAL GRIEVANCES.
WE HAVE SEEN A GROWING THREAT
FROM THOSE WHO ARE MOTIVATED BY
RACIAL AND THOSE DESCRED TOEXTRD
ANTI-AUTHORITY IDEOLOGY.
I DECIDED TO ESTABLISH A
DOMESTIC TERRORISM UNIT FOR
EXISTING APPROACH.
STEVE: WE HAVE RUN OUT OF WORDS
TO EXPRESS HOW DANGEROUS AND
FRIGHTENING THIS ALL IS.
IF YOUR ANTI-AUTHORITY YOU ARE
DOMESTIC TERRORIST.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH BIDEN YOUR
DOMESTICNEMY AND IF YOU SPEAK
OUT AND TRY TO PROTECT FREE
SPEECH AND DEMOCRACY YOU ARE THE
AUTHORITARIAN AS BIDEN
APPROACHES HIS FIRST YEAR IN
OFFICE WHAT A DISASTER THE
ECONOMY, THE PANDEMIC, T
BORDER, FOREIGN POLICY,
EVERYTHING IN CHAOS AND FAILURE,
BIDEN SHOULD HAVE BEEN IMPEACHED
OVER AFGHANISTAN, HE SHOULD BE
REMOVED OVER THE 25th
AMENDMENT OFIS STABILITY BUT
AFTER THE RENT IN ATLANTA WE CAN
SAY FOR SURE IF HE HAD ANY
DECENCY, ANY DIGNITY HE WOULD
RESIGN IN SHAME OVER THE HATE